I guess tonight as a cast member I'm
starting out live and a fantastic
comedian I've had the pleasure of
working with on a number of occasions
he's just killing it across the board
please welcome our friend Chris Redd
Chris how you doing I'm good man I'm
sitting here with my green couch and all
of my blankets and I'm feeling good
really that's how you're battling kovat
is just with a lot of blankets yeah man
I feel like I feel like the more
blankets you have the more protection
against all sorts of nasty things like
chills embrace it there's no science
behind any of this but you feel better
I'm happy that's okay first of all let's
talk about so much to mention but I want
I got to talk about this right away you
raised three hundred and sixty thousand
dollars actually over three hundred and
sixty thousand dollars for something
that you came up with all on your own
called kovat 19 protest relief fund I
want to talk about this right away
because it's so important and inspiring
tell us what that fund does it's
basically a fun for protestors who are
out on the front lines fighting in this
what I call them the uprising for our
justice and equality and in the midst of
our pandemic and putting the risks in
their bodies on the line some of them
being in high in immunities that are
already at high risk and I was like man
there should be some kind of relief for
a treatment for some bills for some bill
relief for injury seeing all of the
attacks that were happening on
protesters just for just for using their
American right to speak out so I just
wanted to do something because I was I
was uh I was having a bunch of different
conversations with folks and including
my family who's high-risk so I couldn't
be outside when the protests were
happening and I was like now usually am
so I'm like damn I kind of feel a little
useless in this whole movement I need to
do something and I was like man is a lot
of bodies out there somebody should come
up with it I felt like a relief funds
like somebody should do that when I said
somebody I met like the government
because it's like their job
ah but I you know I guess that was like
yeah
wishing too much so then I said that for
like two weeks and then I was like well
why don't you do that
just just started GoFundMe got people do
it all the time I never done a GoFundMe
before so I just I just kind of googled
how to GoFundMe and just within the site
did it and I was like hoping that it
would maybe catch on some other people
like there are more prominent would
would do would do it and make I didn't
know what we would make that much money
and by the fifth hour we we were like I
already over eighty eighty thousand
dollars and I was like oh man I need to
figure out how to get money to the
people cuz I don't play with people's
money
you know so that became a three week
crash course getting getting to know
organizers across the country getting to
act activist learning what a nine profit
versus a mutual aid fund was which ours
is a mutual aid fund and and and
learning how it operates because my
whole thing was getting the money to the
people a suit as quickly as we could but
I guess I had the best I was in the best
scenario where it's like usually you
start a mutual aid fund or
not-for-profit and then you're like try
to raise money I had all the money and
no knowledge so between all the help in
the organizers that really educated me
on a lot of a lot of things I needed to
know I was able to set it up in and and
get it going and it's been really cool
to be on the other side of it now where
the logistics are kind of worked out and
now we're just trying to get as much
money out to the people who make us is a
big impact as possible but for you I
mean god bless you that's an amazing
thing to do I would think it would be
kind of I could see you being panicked
if three hundred and six sixty thousand
dollars comes in and you want to get it
to the people but there's this period of
time where the money is just pouring in
and you think like how do I get rid of
this money yeah like being on Breaking
Bad like there's money coming in I gotta
get home just a comic man I wanna make
jokes man there are so many times
Coenen that I almost tweeted I bought a
chain with it instead just just a joke
how to do this I know I know it's a
funny it's a funny joke but people would
get pissed off for a second man
it was it was like a lot of stress
because it was it was a world I'm not
I'm not familiar with but I'm so glad I
did it
and on top of that we've worked with the
Chicago Lions and I know the black lives
matter of Chicago and a bunch of other
organizations just getting matched to
people taking care of tests we begin so
many cool notes about people like be
able to pay their rent because I'm not
behind it in these medical bills and and
there's a lot of people just getting
beat up man a lot of people getting beat
up a lot of phones a lot iPhones were
broken in uprising but we've been able
to take care of folks and that's it and
it's been the best it's been a joy man
it's been something that brings a lot of
lights so what's been a stressful time
for me personally as everybody you know
let me ask you something you left New
York and did you drive to Mississippi is
that right yes so I was I was in New
York for three months during the during
when it was the worst and and like every
other person who was there with me we
get to a point where you're like you
know New York's not built just to live
in your life in your house because this
is very small my my one bedroom I got it
when I first moved here and I was so
busy I just never moved and it is a it's
a studio apartment with someone slapped
the wall in the middle of it it was like
hey but it's a room though as it was as
soon as I got here I was like I gotta
get out I got any space I gotta get out
of here but I want to do as safely as I
can so I had the guy who drives me at
SNL I had I was like yo could you take
me down to Mississippi I know it's a
long way but could you please take me
down there and he was like yes we took
two days a two day trip right it took
two weeks of map out our routes where we
would stop at so we would be safe is my
dad's high risk and I had to like get
tested like three times to make sure
because I guess the test thing were like
67% and so I was like I gotta get tested
a hundred times to know that I'm like
healthy but a weak we did it we got down
there and it was just it was so much it
was so cool to have like space to walk
around
my parents house I would just walk in
the kitchen and just walk around I
didn't even want anything wasn't hungry
I was just walking around because it's
whirling around oh gosh you guys have
this it was amazing it's weird for
people to go back and spend a lot of
time in close quarters with their
parents how do you pass the time when
you're with them what's that like my dad
likes to watch westerns and sit I don't
think the world has changed much for my
pops I he's like I wasn't talking about
in no way so yeah he's did I ever had
before he likes he likes westerns yeah I
got him a fire stick and he was like and
he just learned what bingeing is we just
put him on bingeing I I really caught
him up with technology man but the fire
stick he watches westerns that are so
old there's just like not even pictures
there's just like a guy describing what
the scene is like a guy rides in on
horse and then Indian is he in him no
he's not just a bunch of racist guys
making a movie yeah yeah my mom she like
like loves movie night but only to just
go to bed ten minutes into the movie
oh she passes out oh yeah she passes out
real quick and if she wakes up and tries
to guess what's happening she's just
like oh why did I man live in a box
there is no box there's no man she's
asleep she's like half sleep watching
the movement she's always spoiling it
and she doesn't even know she's doing it
she's like the killer I could tell by
his hat but she's right though I don't
understand a genius oh she's always
right that's funny yeah it she's always
on point it's just like with the
weirdest without like the way his feet
look he definitely kidnapped her like
what that's crazy
my mom's like a big if she is up she's a
big question person like if no matter if
you've seen the movie unnaturally what's
gonna happen I'm seeing it with you lady
I don't know but knives out of something
I saw a bunch and so I was like looking
forward to her like trying to guess the
turns one movie she couldn't eat all the
way figure out and she's like huh it was
almost like she was mad at movie that it
beat her she
I heard you I heard you got into gaming
during during his Cove vid lockdown I
was I'm a workaholic so my whole thing
like why everybody was picking up
hobbies my whole thing was to sit down
and do nothing like my therapist was
like yo you just need to chill and find
something that's not attached to that
you're not trying to monetize like
alright so I started playing Call of
Duty and I got really into it like so
into it that I bought a headset I mean
by head said I bought a headset like
years ago and I just found it in my
house I was like ah this is what this is
for
I as is so then I'm like in it and first
I wouldn't say anything that started
getting good and I was like alright yeah
I'll put the mic down and it became a
real thing and I thought I was gonna
hear a lot of n-words being thrown
around by but just by children but it
was way weirder than that um I the the
biggest thing I heard was a kid yeah as
he was getting is he I got a kill or
something on the game he was like you
didn't even get close to eating my and I
was so confused like he was his
catchphrase coming you even get close to
eat in my what kind of brag is that I
don't know and I just sat in my thoughts
like yo what is this kid's life like I
don't like what is what world so he's
just outside like yeah you will eat my
but you can't though I bet you can't
even get cups which only means one day
someone would eat it yeah yeah yeah yeah
know that taunt tells you a lot there's
a lot going on in there I gotta remember
that
I gotta I gotta remember that the next
time I'm in an argument with somebody at
a gas station this is where I live
to question personal question Chris you
are a single eligible bachelor
what would it take for you to date
during kovat today right now man you
would have to have like test results I'm
really good at picking out who's been
like really wild and who's like actually
been quarantined because I'm like I was
in you know I was here when it was a hot
spot when New York was a hot spot I'm a
ninja with the quarantine I'm
cold-blooded with it mean like gods
wrong so I can actually and and and how
you ask you know act straight out
because people will lie you just get
them real comfortable you just ask so
like man that's crazy so this quarantine
thing giant me crazy I would just love
to kick it with like I collect some
people and I got a little party you know
I mean she's like on the load sick and
then they'll be still say something this
happened she's like yeah you should have
been with us last weekend with this
cabin but don't tell anybody I'm like
how well and I'll see you in 2021 you
reckless mother so it's your own it's
your own sting operation yes what sounds
like you're in a lonely period right now
but that's yeah very lonely I watched a
watch porn so much I think I've seen all
of it and I've started sitting script
notes yeah you're starting to so
brilliant first of all that's something
to say you've watched all the porn not
that I would it's to me yes it's like
it's like is it h DS at 4k HD we don't
we don't actually need it to be that
clear I don't want to see and hear
someone crying I don't need that you
know I'm glad that we started this
conversation with you raising so much
money for kovat 19 protests relief fund
and then as always with me we end up
talking about pornography and how it
could be better well I am I'm thrilled
you're doing such amazing stuff I mean
as an artist but also getting involved
and and and doing what you're doing
I really do salute you I just want to
get the message out you can support the
co vid 19 protein
Relief Fund by going to covet nineteen
protest relief dot-com hey Chris I want
you to stay safe and hang in there is so
great to talk to you and I can't wait
till we get to talk in person I know man
I'm looking forward to it you stay safe
- I alright I got this I got this hair
keep that keep that hair saucy look at
that you know what I'm doing I'm batting
away the covin Oh bat it bad oh bit here
there's Cove it there and I'm just like
it's a whip
let's y'all wear masks only I can do
that all right